certainly I can tell you a little bit
about my background that might be
helpful my first went to the Middle East
as a study abroad student in my junior
year and I studied at the American
University of Cairo then after
graduation I joined the Peace Corps in
Jordan and so i was there in 2001-2002
for about 18 months we got evacuated
before the war in iraq started then i
was a fulbright fellow in Yemen in
2003-2004 and in 2005 I was a fellow for
the American instituted Yemeni studies
and I went back to Yemen in 2006 I led a
group of college university and graduate
students to Yemen as part of a State
Department program for them to study
Arabic and then this last year I was
once again in Yemen in July and August
doing some of my own research for an
upcoming book at the moment I'm working
on two separate projects one is my
dissertation at Princeton which
everyone's very eager for me to finish
mostly my advisor and my my mom and dad
and that's on the Yemeni civil war in
the north in the 1960s and so what I'm
hoping to do is really look at sort of
the internal dynamics of the war there's
been a great deal written about this is
really through the lens of the Arab cold
war talking about Egyptian involvement
Saudi involvement in the war my hope is
to really get at the Yemeni actors
themselves I think in a couple of years
of research that I've done I've had some
great sources and great material the
second project that I'm working on is
much more contemporary and this is to
deal with the history of al-qaeda in
Yemen and Yemeni political history
particularly since unification in 1990
right I think there are a number of
changes that Yemen has on undergone in
the in the past several years I first
went there in 2003 and this is really
very shortly after the the sep tember
11th attacks of course in 2001 and this
is still at least as I tend to analyze
what's happened there in what I like to
call the first phase of the war against
Al Qaeda so from that point in in 2003
to my most recent trip in July and
August of 2009 a great deal has changed
the the tension within Sanaa is
something that I noticed a great deal on
my last trip it was something that even
while almost ironically the the number
of weapons that are being carried within
the city of Sanaa has been greatly
reduced the government has done a very
good job of attempting to control the
small arms that different individuals
carry particularly within the city
limits of Sanaa not so much outside but
while that well that number has went
down the tensions have actually
increased and this as a result at least
in my view of the civil war that's going
on up in the north in Saada the
resurgent al-qaeda threat as well as the
increasing in increasingly I think
violent calls for secession from the
south so that was something that really
really stood out to me another thing and
this is just by way of anecdote that one
very good Yemeni friend a journalist who
who's I think a very astute observer of
Yemeni politics said was he told me that
I can no longer tell the difference
between al-qaeda in the mosques and
al-qaeda in the caves and I think this
is something that should be a great
cause for concern it was a something
that I took away from the trip as being
very very worried about I think this
really gets at the idea that al-qaeda is
putting a message in a narrative out
with in Yemen that really isn't being
combated at any meaningful level either
by the Yemeni government or by the US
government or even by different clerics
and sheriffs and scholars within the
Yemeni with in Yemen who tend to
disagree with them
certainly I think when I think that I
guess the best way to get at this is
sort of to give you a little snapshot of
Yemen because i think when talking about
Yemen when thinking about Yemen it's
really really easy to become overwhelmed
by just the the totality of the crises
that the country faces and so I tend to
view the country as having these three
separate layers of crises if you will at
the top there's this elite rivalry
there's the struggle for power this is
taking place behind closed doors but
it's something that really I think
affects all the other levels of layers
of crises within the country President
Ali Abdullah Saleh has been president
since 1978 he saw the country through
unification in 1990 he saw the country
through the civil war that happened four
years later when the trash out the
attempted to secede and he continues to
really I think maintain this delicate
balancing act he likes to claim that
ruling Yemen is like dancing on the
heads of snakes and this is something
that he's done very very well but it's
something that increasingly it seems as
if he's losing a little bit of his grip
now whether this is just because he's
getting older or whether this is because
he's running out of money and is no
longer sort of able to play different
opposition groups off against one
another is keeping them all perpetually
dependent I think that's still a little
bit of an open question but what we have
now is all these this next generation of
leaders if you will so you have the
president's son you have a quartet of
nephews who are all sort of attempting
to position themselves to seize power
once the president eventually leaves in
addition to that you have another very
powerful family a tribal family the the
alotta family who's also attempting to
seize power or at least position
themselves in a place where they could
have a shot at taking power and so this
is all going on at the top it's
something that people with in Yemen talk
about speculate on but but it's very
much sort of palace politics something
that there's much more rumor than fact
then below this we have in this second
layer if you will we have a trio of
security crisis we have the of course
resurgent al-qaeda threat we have the
Civil War up in the north
ruthie rebellion that I referenced
earlier and then the calls for secession
from the south so these the this trio of
security challenges I think really
grabbed the majority of the headlines in
2008-2009 and as we move forward
particularly the al-qaeda threat will
will grab most of the headlines in the
future then below this we have I think
what could really be described as sort
of a almost the structural challenges to
the state this is the fact that the
state which is heavily depended upon oil
revenue is running out of oil it's
losing water the water table is dropping
by say six to eight meters in some areas
of the country which for a country where
the vast majority of the population
still is dependent upon subsistence
agriculture for their livelihood this is
a very significant thing there's rampant
corruption in the government a very high
birthrate correspondingly very low rates
of literacy within the country
unemployment is very high poverty is
very high so you really at this level
you have sort of a laundry list and so
that's sort of the the snapshot of Yemen
at least as I see it at the moment
right i think one of the the best ways
to sort of get at this is to talk about
these two distinct phases of the war
against against al qaeda al Qaeda's
roots in Yemen are fairly deep they go
back into the early and mid 1990s Yemen
had sent a lot of individuals off to
fight in Afghanistan during the 1980s
against the the Soviet Union there they
were unlike most of the Arab countries
however Yemen welcomed most of these
fighters back places like Egypt places
like Algeria they really didn't want
these guys coming back Yemen however let
them come back and so throughout the
1990s you really had I think what could
best be described as a tacit
non-aggression pact between the Yemeni
government and these fighters president
Saleh one of his comrades from his home
village a very powerful military
commander named Ali Muhsin al-ahmad they
really utilize these returning fighters
during the nineteen ninety-four civil
war against their socialist enemies so
for these fighters who had fought in
Afghanistan what you had is they
defeated the Communists there and they
came back to Yemen and were once again
fighting communists within the Yemeni
context however this started to change
in 2000 with the USS Cole attack and
then really after September 11th when I
think president Saleh felt as though
Yemen was was next after Afghanistan on
on a u.s. hit list so Yemen was quite
worried that the u.s. was going to carry
out some strikes within the country that
it was going to go after the government
go after individuals go after Yemenis
largely because of this dubious history
that the Yemeni government had had with
some of these individuals and so
president Saleh was quite concerned
about this he had his son Ahmed send a
letter to King Abdullah of Jordan who
was in Washington at the time he
dispatched a top-level adviser to come
to Washington and then president Saleh
followed that up with a trip to
Washington in november 2001 and this is
really when the Yemeni government got
very serious about combating al-qaeda
president Saleh had a meeting with then
President Bush and Bush essentially told
him look this is how you show the u.s.
that you're on our side here's a list of
all Qaeda operatives in the country you
need to go after them you need to either
arrest them or kill them
so when President Saleh returned to
Yemen he dispatched the military
counterterrorism forces to different
places within the country where he was
going to go after these individuals the
first strike on a village out in out in
moderate in December of 2001 did not go
well the head of al-qaeda a man named
Abu Ali al-harithi who the Yemeni
government was after managed to escape
the Yemeni military perform rather
poorly they lost a number of individuals
who were killed as well as a number of
other soldiers who were taken captive by
by tribesmen so at this point the u.s.
realized that if it wanted to do
something in Yemen it was going to have
to take a more proactive role take a
more leadership role and so this is then
if we'll sort of skip ahead to November
2002 where the US and the CIA carried
out the unmanned predator drone strike
that actually killed this man Abu Ali
al-harithi unfortunately for us Yemeni
security cooperation at this time
someone in the Pentagon leaked news of
the strike the strike took place on
November third 2002 there were midterm
elections if you'll remember on November
fifth 2002 and so this was seen sort of
as a way to show the u.s. population
that look the Bush administration is
serious we have this early victory and
what was then called the war on terror
but of course that leaked played much
different in the u.s. than it did in
Yemen in Yemen it was seen as the Yemeni
government being sold out to us domestic
political concerns and in fact a number
of Yemeni political advisors said
publicly look this is why we can't work
with the US any time something like this
happens were hung out to dry and so that
was really the zenith of the u.s. Yemeni
security cooperation it was also a major
strike a year later in november 2003
yemen arrested mohamed hem dialectal who
had replaced Abu Ali al-harithi as the
head of al-qaeda and that really brought
an end to the sort of this first phase
of the war against Al Qaeda then from
that point up until februari 2006 there
was very little almost no al Qaeda
violence in the country and then in
February 2006 there was a a prison break
where 23 al-qaeda suspects including a
former personal aide to Osama bin Laden
tunneled out of a political security
prison
in sanaa into a neighboring maust where
they said their morning prayers then
they walked out the front door to
freedom and these individuals this
nostril rahasia this personal aide to
bin Laden as well as costs amauter Amy
really did a very very good job of
rebuilding reorganizing it really
resurrecting al Qaeda in Yemen up from
the ashes and they're also a much
different a much more radical group than
the previous versions of al Qaeda that
we had seen in the country so this
organization under all the way she and
Audrey me they've done a very very good
job of tailoring and narrative to fit
the Yemeni context so they put
themselves on the right side of nearly
every issue from local corruption to the
israeli-palestinian conflict to flooding
and HUD remote and almira I mean this is
an organization that really knows what
it's doing and has built this sort of
durable infrastructure that will
withstand the loss of key leaders so
unlike what happened in this first phase
where you could kill a ball al harthy
and the organization would sort of
crumble down around itself this is no
longer the case with this with this new
group
well this is something that I think is
the subject of a great deal of
speculation certainly in my view there's
been a militarization of US policy
towards Yemen which i think is is a
grave mistake and will have I think what
it does is essentially pursue short-term
benefits which unfortunately will in my
opinion have exceedingly high long-term
costs the US has sent a number of
Special Forces Joint Special Operations
Command CIA they all have a very active
presence within Yemen senator Lieberman
talked about this senator Lieberman
traveled to Yemen in August of 2009
along with Senator McCain and a couple
of other individuals I was in touch with
his staff when he was going and so he he
i think it is right that the u.s. does
have a very active sort of covert
military presence there we've seen this
in recent months prior to the december
25th failed attempt to blow up the
detroit airliner we saw a series of
strikes on december 17th there were a
number of strikes allegedly carried out
with us missiles unfortunately i think
this was also counterproductive because
while the missiles did hit some of their
targets they did kill some al-qaeda
individuals they also killed a number of
women and children and this is something
that was immediately put up on giati
forums so you would see these corpses of
women and children and they're all
captioned and sort of headlined with the
made in the USA caption and this is
something that I think goes a long way
towards increasing and really extending
the appeal that al-qaeda has with in
Yemen more recently we've seen a number
of strikes about a week and a half ago
in early January there was a strike that
would have killed casa madre me this
individual I talked about who was who's
now the military commander and really
third in charge in this al Qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula but he's an individual
that myself as well as I believe a
number of individuals who are well
informed within the US government
considered to be the single most
dangerous individual within the
organization he was reported to have
been killed the Yemeni government made a
huge deal about this the Yemeni
government claimed that it had carried
out the strike but most informed
observers believe that if it did it was
acting on
US intelligence or that the u.s. itself
actually carried out the strike but of
course having learned from what we
talked about in november two thousand
and two sort of the risks of exposing
all of this the obama administration
seems to have learned that hubris in
this isn't always the best policy
however unfortunately for the US and
Yemeni government's it appeared that
Casa Monterey me as well as the other
seven individuals who were targeted in
that strike in January of 2010 all
escaped in fact al-qaeda put out a
statement that said look don't trust the
Yemeni government when it puts this
stuff out it's it's just propaganda wait
until you hear stuff from us that is
going to be authenticated that is going
to be put through the proper channels on
jihadi forums and that's the stuff that
you can trust these are the statements
these are the videos that you can trust
and al-qaeda has said this over and over
over the past several months and really
I think it's to be quite frank it's a
it's a very sad state of affairs when
people like myself outside observers
trust the statements that al-qaeda puts
out much more than the statements that
the Yemeni government puts out
well I think it would be a catastrophic
mistake to put us boots on the ground in
Yemen I think there are a lot of things
that the USA can do which it hasn't
really done the US has really seen Yemen
through the prism of al-qaeda
essentially just looked at the country
as this counterterrorism problem that
has to be solved and you I think
ironically that the u.s. is insistence
on seeing the country that way by
linking nearly all of its aid to the
single issue has actually induced
exactly the type of results that the
u.s. is hoping to avoid so the u.s.
can't deal with al-qaeda in isolation of
all of youngins other problems the
country has to be dealt with as a whole
and I think in in Yemen there is a great
and I believe growing fear that if
al-qaeda were to go away US aid and
interest in the country would also go
away and this is something that Yemenis
point to not only the history of the US
over the past 10 years say how high US
aid an interest was in 2001-2002 then
see the drop-off in 04 05 and 06 but
also how the US has dealt with countries
like Pakistan and Afghanistan during the
1990s so the u.s. is really working I
think against a great deal of muscle
memory here that it has to overcome
there are a number of steps that the
u.s. can can take these have to be I
think coordinated both internationally
and regionally and it also i think
demands a sort of localized and nuanced
knowledge that the US doesn't appear to
have when it comes to yemen nor for that
matter do sort of regional countries
like Saudi Arabia or some of Yemen's
other neighbors and I would in fact say
it would be a mistake if the US were to
attempt to run its Yemen policy through
Riyadh or through Saudi Arabia but at
the same time it has to bring Saudi
Arabia and it has to bring a number of
these other countries in but it can do a
lot on public diplomacy it can do a lot
on peeling away different individuals
who are now joining al Qaeda because we
know that these individuals really
weren't sort of constructed to join
al-qaeda that all Qaeda is something
that's a mirage but these in in really
the absence of anything else these
people are going after that Mirage